so when we were doing research um on you
that means I was just stalking you
online uh my team came across um some
Nick Jonas facts okay so there's a lot
of lies out there
um and there's a lot of Truth so we want
to know if you will answer these like
what is fact and what is fiction oh
interesting yes okay you don't have a
choice so here we go okay welcome to my
show okay so Nick Jonas can't whistle
um you can't whistle that is a fact what
all right so I have newly discovered
that I can I can make a sound that is a
whistle sound that was sad but I can't
whistle like a tune oh okay so like I
can't whistle a song but I can just go
that's the extent of my whistle that was
like the saddest whistle heard around
the world
and sometimes I can't even get it
sometimes it's just
it's just okay I did not know that about
you okay so Nick Jonas's favorite part
of the cake is the icing that's uh
that's kind of a fact okay I like the
combo the cake and the icing I like them
both too but it's nice chemistry I I'm
not like a big cake guy I actually have
pie on my birthday oh I love pie I'm a
big pumpkin pie guy that's my favorite
pie best pie ah hands down so the whole
thing is like the Cake part like I could
just kind of dip my finger and enjoy the
icing and then be done and then go get a
pie I will say pie is better better pie
is better than cake I'm with you okay
okay Nick was in a Chuck E cheese
commercial when he was younger what do
you think of the answer I think that
would be super cool I love Chuck E
cheese even at 40 like with my kids yeah
yeah so like I love Chuck E cheese and
as a kid I think that would be really
cool and I feel like you're cool she
probably did do that I did that you did
that you did
you did like what
did you get to hang with the band like
the mouse did you get to yeah so when I
was uh you know a kid and I was doing
acting in Broadway and music and stuff
yeah uh I would go on auditions for
things all the time there was two big
jobs that you wanted to get as like a
child actor yeah Northeast one was the
Hess truck holiday commercials I don't
know if you've ever seen that is that
but it was like a big deal it was a song
uh it was a whole thing and I never got
it ah so mad but I did get the other I
would say second most desirable job well
I've never heard of that and I've heard
of Chuck E cheese because I think it's
National Commercial whereas the Hess
truck was a local commercial I think but
the National Commercial was Chuck E
cheese and I got it and I got to do this
cool thing where I'm sitting on like the
skee ball uh yeah and I I threw it
behind my back and it went up and went
into the the thing yeah and we did the
first shot and I got it I actually got
it in because they're gonna like CGI it
and uh I got a high five from the
director and yeah from from Chuck E
Cheese's yeah it's pretty cool that's
cool and they gave me a thousand tokens
wow which which is like equivalent to
like I think winning the lottery as a
child but yeah
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]